Speaker 1: I do want to take a quick look
at The David Pakman Show sub Reddit.
Find it at David Pakman Dotcom it.
Now, more than 31000 of you subscribed to
the sub Reddit.
Here is a post that I find interesting, and
it's called Sometimes I Fear being judged
for not wearing a mask after being fully vaccinated.
And this viewer says right now in California,
June 15th, the mask mandate is going away.
And I'm personally pretty excited for it.
I was fully vaccinated in March, got my first
dose in February when I randomly got a text
saying my local vaccination clinic had spare
doses.
I immediately lined up.
I've been seeing a lot of comments on left
YouTube videos and Subrata saying what the
CDC did was stupid or we should keep wearing
masks forever because they prevent the flu.
And that kind of worries me.
Not that I'm judging anyone for continuing
to wear a mask, but that people might decide
to yell at me or judge me for not wearing
one at a grocery store without a mandate once
the California mask mandate is gone.
I've heard stories in San Francisco of people
getting harassed outdoors for not wearing
a mask, even though it's been months since
the CDC and California government said it
was OK.
Do you think people will end up judging me
or seeing me as a Republican if I stop wearing
a mask indoors once the California mandate
is gone?
Yeah, I mean, the truth is some people will
and there's going to be a readjustment period.
And I think that people essentially just have
to decide.
What is more important to you is the belief
and understanding that the CDC guidelines
for vaccinated people feel OK to you.
More important than the fact that a couple
of people might give you a dirty look because
you're not wearing a mask.
And it's just a very personal decision.
As I've said before, I think it's great to
have the possibility of wearing a mask and
for it to be normalized during flu season,
and particularly if not only if if in November,
it starts looking like we're having a heavy
flu season against which I will be vaccinated,
I get my flu vaccine and covid cases start
going up.
I will be glad to when I go.
I mean, the real place I'm thinking of is
the grocery store or public transit.
I'll be glad to go back to wearing a mask.
I think that that's a great thing.
That being said, right now, with cases so
low, with the variance so well controlled
by the vaccine, by the by all vaccines, I'm
comfortable not wearing a mask outdoors.
And when it comes to indoors, just doing what
the location requires.
And if they don't require require wearing
a mask, I'm comfortable not doing it.
And is anybody judging me?
Probably.
Probably, but I'm completely comfortable with
it.
It's a very personal thing and I think a lot
of it is just personality driven.
What what is more important to you saying
there's no reason for me to wear a mask based
on the medical guidelines.
So I'm not going to regardless of the consequences
or I value more the way that people see me,
even if it's random people.
That's a very personal decision that really
only you can make for yourself.
Another interesting post on the subhead.
It asks, how do you guys stay sane?
I just finished Pakman show from yesterday.
And I've got to say, it's depressing.
From gridlock in the Senate to Trump still
having a large base of support, I find myself
so discouraged and turned off by politics
right now.
How do you guys keep from being this way going
on to say later, I live and work in a very
conservative area, so I'm inundated with this
stuff all the time.
I hear really racist, homophobic things at
work all the time.
How do my fellow liberals in conservative
areas cope with the latter part?
I can't answer, but I think it is really healthy.
To check out from the news for a few days,
every single week when I'm done producing
the Friday show, I do not pay attention to
the news unless something major happens or
unless I stumble across something because
I turn the TV on or look at Facebook.
I am checking out of news for almost three
days every week.
OK, that's like almost half the week in a
sense.
I think it's imperative.
I think it's absolutely imperative to maintain
sanity.
And I would encourage I would encourage people
to do it.
And then the other thing is.
Adopt a bit of stoic philosophy about really
understanding what is within your locus of
control and what is not, because there are
always things to be upset about, because so
many upsetting things are happening.
But to some degree, understanding the limits,
can we activate about something and try to
influence a political issue?
Great.
Let's do it.
But understand that you can't control the
outcomes of everything that's happening.
And to some degree, we've got to continue
living our lives and making the best we can
of them.
So I think that that would be my advice.
But I'm right there with you two really good
posts today.
Make your own post and maybe it'll make it
onto the show next week on the sub.
Read it, find it at David Pakman.
Dotcom slash.
R.E.D.
Ditt